[Music]  angelina jolie opens up about adjusting  to single life it's lovely well not  exactly it's been a year since angelina  split from husband brad pitt and now the  42 year old actress is getting extremely  candid about life on her own in a new  interview with sunday telegraph angelina  explains i don't enjoy being single it's  not something i wanted there's nothing  nice about it it's just hard the mother  of six also says she may look like she's  quote pulling it all together but  reveals really i'm just trying to get  through my days emotionally it's been a  very difficult year we are a family and  we will always be a family  and we will get through this time and  and hopefully be a stronger family  angelina went on to say she's  rediscovering her old self quote i think  we lose our way a bit and it's been a  very good time to absorb and develop and  grow very very lucky  [Music]